I think everything we do is at one with
toilet
we're evolved for that we're wired for
that the question is how big do we want
our tribe to be England seems to be
saying we want our tribe to end in our
Shores ISIL it's a point of view I
understand is it's it's a legitimate
point of view equally legitimate is the
opposite point of view where there
should be a broader pan European tribe
as it were to protect itself and
reinforce itself in a dangerous world
that's also tribalism it's just a matter
of how big do you draw the tribe at its
essence at its core every individual has
to decide whether they're an individual
or they are they part of a larger group
are they part of their neighborhood are
they part of their community or do they
just exist to serve themselves
what England is facing is something that
every single human being in the world
faces at some level in their lives about
their own personal interest versus the
interests of their group I personally I
think that democracy is a messy
experiment and there's a lot of
discourse a lot of conflict a lot of
argument a lot of debate and a lot of
dislike I mean we're not required to
like each other I think about the
platoon that I was with in combat the
most stressful environment conceivable
there was a lot there was a lot of
dislike within the platoon there were
guys who didn't like each other at all
but the one thing they never did was
speak with contempt about one another
they argued they fought they disagreed
but they respected each other and you
don't disrespect someone inside the wire
as it were what's disturbing right now
in this country is that there are very
very powerful people politicians and
media leaders who are disrespecting
other people inside the wire they are
speaking with real contempt and derision
about their president about aspects of
the government about segments of the
popular
you just don't do that you never know
when you'll need those people for
survival when you when your life will
depend on those people or you'll be
asked to save their lives the idea that
this country can't overnight be turned
into one huge Combat Outpost is absurd
we just don't know what's going to
happen and so when you have politicians
speaking like that it's not just the
messy debate of democracy it really
undermines the basis of our of our
country the moral basis of our democracy
it's much more dangerous to our
democracy than Isis is or al Qaeda is it
also is a good campaign strategy and
that's the tragedy right I mean you have
politicians who appeal to what kind of
tribalism by saying look it's us against
them and that them are actually other
citizens in this country when you do
that you create very very strong support
in your base but it's at the long-term
consequence that you're talking about
the country as if it's being split in
two it's a little like marriage
counselors advise you know just don't
say the word divorce within your
conversations as a couple that the idea
of splitting up is not acceptable and
what I would say personally as a citizen
to politicians is stop talking about
this country as if it's conceivable that
it's actually two countries just don't
do it because you're starting a very
very dangerous dialogue that you and you
don't know where it's going to end well
this country is an example of a moderate
country that has overcome its internal
divisions and has existed for 240 years
as a nation and I mean we've had a lot
of rocky times and unfair laws and
everything else but we're a nation of
330 million people and we're still
together the democracies of Europe
likewise I mean it's not pretty but
neither's family life I mean no one
guaranteed you pretty you know what I
mean but it is working and it's a
continual work in progress what we all
have to do I believe
is keep reminding each other of our of
our best qualities an interesting thing
about humans is that the worse the
situation the better we act when you
have the flood the hurricane the civil
war the Blitz in London whatever it may
be that's when people really step up and
achieve a kind of loyalty to the common
good a kind of selflessness kind of
blindness to race and politics and
religion and everything else that can
divide us and as things get better as
circumstances get better and easier
people start to act worse and I think
it's very very helpful to remind your
fellow citizens and remind yourself that
in our very darkest days we all act
quite well and that's what that's what
we should aspire to throughout the
course of our lives and throughout the
course of our democracy